let me tell you what happened today I'm
driving down the street I got my
convertible Mustang now I always rent a
car
that
I've never owned but I think maybe I
would what it's like my test drive right
I've rent Tesla everything Tesla I've
run to I'm not a sports car dude but I
like muscle cars I like you know
so I'm like I'm gonna try this
convertible Mustang you know I like a
little room for it and so yo I'm on
Ventura Boulevard today
and I'm in my convertible
and
from
the car in front of me
I'm driving out the sunroof
no joke this is that out the sunrise
thrown this way that landed
or like
not
on my car but like we were selling
like front left tire
and I'm like what because I was like
that looks like
an arm
like like un like an arm
hard to mistake an arm
and and now look man if this is this
dude's joke it [__] works do you know
what I mean if he's like well I'm gonna
look I'm gonna freak everybody out
and they this armless dude comes out of
the car
people are they like turns green people
start to honk and he's like sorry
everybody just having some fun
dude just walked by picked up his arm
picked up the arm waved it at me so the
hand waved I was like this is the best
day of my [__] life
this dude without an arm was like I'm
sure was like you want to see me
freaking people out and just [__]
through his arm
his [__] no it wasn't a deal though
Cameron I believe it or not know the
difference between an arm and a dick
not everybody does
but but I have to tell you what what I
really liked about this dude was
if it wasn't me
if it was just your normal average
person who isn't into the weird
yeah they even freaked the [__] out but
I was like is that an arm is that a
[__] arm oh my God is this like is it
Christmas our arms falling out of the
[__] sky like holy
[__]
[Music]
that's how big her titties were they
made that noise through the air